joining me now for reaction is Sean
Duffy a Republican congressman from
Wisconsin and with me here in the studio
is Philippe rhinos an advisor to Hillary
Clinton's 2016 campaign gentlemen great
to see both of you this Friday night
let's start with you Philippe look this
lost it I read it I read all 64 pages I
believe it 64 pages and it is goofy I'm
sorry it's just a goofy I mean are you
are they gonna serve like Vladimir Putin
with papers this to me looks like they
they're not getting what they want from
the special counsel the Russia collusion
things going nowhere
so maybe something will happen with
Cohen but they have to desperately keep
this thing to howand it to keep it you
know breathing more air in the fire
until the midterms is this the real deal
or well I'm not a lawyer but I
understand your point and you know I
don't know congressman Duffy bear with
me while I make a point he was elected
in 2010 you always do a little research
on the guest year I was hoping he'd be
every time you could you come up with a
little tidbit I work for someone I like
to be prepared he one decent leaves
first and you've won handily your last
two and with all due respect I hope you
lose in November because I'm a Democrat
and I'd like to flip the house but I
want you to lose fair and square or win
fair and square I don't want anyone
meddling and I know no one likes to
admit that but the problem I think we're
in now is that it is such a Hillary
Clinton blames Russia thing that no one
is talking about Russians or Chinese or
North Koreans or whoever it may be
screwing around with our election and
the point I'm going to make about the
court is that because it's a Republican
Congress there are no bills to protect
the election this is something the
lawsuit can't be fired
go ahead Sean Laura this is outrageous
force all I mean it's rich that the DNC
is trying to file a lawsuit about Russia
clusion the very DNC that hired and
funded a dossier with information that
came from Russian informants they're the
ones that colluded with the Russians
beyond that if you I don't know why they
didn't name Barack Obama who didn't do
anything in the election of 16 to stop
the Russian involve
in the election or James call me who
came out in two press releases on his
investigation but frankly I think the
DNC should have included Garmin and
Google Maps because Hillary Clinton
couldn't seem to find Wisconsin on the
map become a campaign I mean to come and
make up these excuses about why
Democrats lost I think is pathetic they
had a bad message they had a bad
candidate Donald Trump understood that
he had to go out in and win the
electorate with a set of ideas that they
bought into that's why we won and from I
I agree with your point
I hope the Democrats keep talking about
Russia I hope they keep Nancy Pelosi in
the leadership position because we're
focusing on ideas that grow the economy
that make people's lives better and
their families and Democrats can't get
beyond why they lost a lot last election
and Russia Russia Russia Gloria Borger
was on CNN say she's no great fan of the
presidents and Phillipe maybe you'll
respond to this this is what she said
about the lawsuit honestly it's just
it's just a way to raise money and
that's what they're trying to do they're
trying to raise money off of it but I
think this is just one more way to get
into the act here okay and continue what
they've been doing all along okay well
look I'd make I'd make two points one is
president Trump's own intelligence
community has says the Russians are
going to medal in 2018 so unless the
congressman doesn't agree with that I do
think there has to be steps to protect
on the lawsuit thing I'll be honest with
you without being a lawyer I'm glad that
Democrats are doing this because the
Republican Party has very effectively
used outlets like Judicial Watch and
others that in a matter words moveon.org
we think progress but they don't sue did
our watch is very effective
well it's for your requests yeah request
okay well I want to talk about something
that's kind of fun this is fun this is
for you listen no it's fine this is the
new book out by Amy chose ik of the New
York Times and we have a couple of fun
little extra bits so she covered Hillary
Clinton for ten years okay and the book
is called chasing Hillary ten years two
presidential campaigns in one intact
glass ceiling because it's she lost
because she's a woman don't you know
this is one quote this is what Hillary
says on a
election night I knew it I knew this
what happened to me should I do it in
her voice I knew this would happen to me
they were never going to let me be
president
really by the way this was not fun I
hope the next part smut I look I think
look she was disappointed I was in the
room with her yeah things were going bad
and I'm like five second you know I
think that it was hard to take and she
knew immediately that a series of things
why didn't she come out and do a
concession speech that was lying because
both campaigns had agreed to wait until
aap called it honestly I was in the room
when she caught Trump this is this is a
great quote today what the deplorable
wouldn't let me win and lat what is she
entitled to be the president it's a it's
for America you earned the presidency
you quote and earn the vote and she
thinks she's entitled that they won't
let me be the president listen this this
quote encompasses everything is wrong
with Hillary Clinton she felt like she
could just say I'm a Clinton bill was my
husband and I'm entitled to win this
election without working without giving
a vision in the direction for the
country it's frankly shameful but you
know what she'll never go away she's
used to being in the press well you
wants to see her name's on the what's
that party and the and Fox won't let her
go away you'd think she was pretty we
don't even get into the mention every
Friday night guys
we let you off the book